mais quelle bande menzah anthropologue
spécialiste de la nouvelle calédonie de
la culture du peuple kanak bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous c'est clairement
la perspective de ce nouveau référendum
qui déclenche
ces tensions en nouvelle-calédonie selon
vous oui je pense que c'est la terre ce
truc qui devrait faire un drame je pense
que c'est aussi le résultat des
élections municipales et des élections
provinciales et qui a montré une sorte
de radicalisation dans l'est dans les
deux camps et qui a un peu pénalisé le
discours modéré fondée sur la
construction qui de calédonie dans
laquelle les kanak sera pleinement des
acteurs en face de gens qui seraient
associés à cette émancipation globale du
pays et donc ce qui devait arriver est
en train d'arriver sert de référendum
renforce ses dépositions les pluies les
plus tranchées et met sous le bois sont
les points de vue les plus modérés qui
pourraient tirer parti d'abord de tout
ce qui a été fait en nouvelle calédonie
depuis trente ans il pousser plus loin
pour trouver une solution originale qui
serait une indépendance en partenariat
avec la français c'est bien ce que
demande une grande partie des
indépendants qui se plient l'échiné
alors vous vite les tensions se sont
vraiment exacerbée notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux avec quelques tensions
qui peuvent éclater dans la rue on l'a
vu le le 14 juillet
justement ces réseaux sociaux pour vous
elles ont été de nature à libérer une
forme de parole très radicale c'est un
peu là comme partout partout dans le
monde puisque l'expression spontanée
échappe à tout système de représentation
démocratique et libère il parole
absolument incontrôlable bon alors entre
ce qu'il dit sur les réseaux sociaux et
puis le vote le respect des règles du
référendum la mise en place quand même
de politique publique que ce soit dans
les provinces des ide ont dû donner du
nord qui sont tenus par les
indépendantistes ou dans la province sud
il ya quand même un esprit de
responsabilité bien heureusement nous
permet de dépasser les petites fictions
superficielle des réseaux sociaux alors
en novembre 2010 18 ans plus de 56% des
électeurs avaient voté non à
l'indépendance selon vous les choses
ont-elles changé depuis
on va voir la majorité effectivement été
pour le non à l'indépendance mais les
indépendantistes qu'on avait un peu trop
vite crédit ctic scores très bas voire
de 20% ont affiché de très forte
mobilisation qui leur a permis de rester
dans le débat sur l'avenir de la
nouvelle calédonie avec un score qui
avoisinait les 40 4% et bien entendu je
pense pas que dans le prochain
référendum les indépendantistes puisse
l'emporter ce qu'on pourrait espérer
c'est que l'écart se réduise entre les
indépendantistes et ceux qui n'y sont
pas favorables pour véritablement ouvrir
en fait une nouvelle phase qui serait le
prolongement de l'accord de nouméa qui
fait un mort en discussion de l'avenir
de la nouvelle calédonie pour n'y
trouver les bases solides dans le
respect de chacun
quels sont les arguments brandis par les
kanaks justement qui veulent leur
indépendance les ans
du vendredi sont des arguments quelque
sorte historique comptait d'ailleurs et
il a fermé par le cos vite 19 si vous
voulez c'est le fait d'avoir subi de
plein fouet et pendant 150 ans de régime
colonial extrêmement dur qui a marqué
les mémoires qui a marqué les
comportements et que les gens n'ont pas
oublié il aimerait bien que cet affront
qu'il aura été fait ou 19e et jusqu'en
1946 au xxème siècle que cet affront
soit lavé et qu'ils puissent avoir le
sentiment d'être des citoyens à part
entière
donc il ya beau y theater là encore de
récriminations et puis le bien entendu
les plus jeunes les gens quelques fois
ci qui ont tendance à simplifier les
problèmes se complaisent un peu dans
cette dans cette radicalisation d'avion
exact avoir une chose en france et dans
le monde donc respirer gens puissent
raison garder il ya beaucoup de travaux
qui naît au jour où on lit ce qui s'est
véritablement passé durant la
colonisation et qui montre que
effectivement elle a été très très dur
mais que une parole de paix ou un espoir
de concorde n'a jamais été abandonnée y
compris par les victimes même de la
colonisation qui sont le kanak
merci beaucoup allemand benza d'avoir
été avec nous et nous avoir apporté
votre analyse en direct sur rt france